We embarked upon the "Cocoa supplement
and multivitamin outcome study" otherwise
known as COSMOS to evaluate whether
taking a supplement daily that has
cocoa flavanols in it over the course
of four years of treatment and follow-up
would reduce the risk of major
cardiovascular events over time.
Well the cocoa flavonols are not the
same thing as chocolate. Chocolate is a
wonderful treat but it's not a reliable
source of cocoa flavanols so there are
cocoa flavanol products available that don't
have the sugar, the fat, or the calories
and these are the products that have
been tested in many of the recent
small-scale randomized trials
suggesting benefits for reducing risk of
heart disease and stroke and also
avoiding memory loss. One of the
advantages of the COSMOS trial is the
amount of cocoa flavanols that we're
testing, which is about 600 milligrams
per day, would not be easily translatable
into something that you can get through
diet alone and in fact the amount of
cocoa flavanols that we're testing in
the COSMOS trial would result in such
high chocolate intake you'd be eating too
much chocolate and other forms of cocoa
products to try and get that equivalent
amount of cocoa flavanols which we
believe the bioactive component of the
cocoa bean, the cocoa powder that matters
the most in terms of vascular health.